in den letzten wochen habe ich dieses
buch gelesen und ich war hingerissen
geschrieben hat es der chefredakteur des
us-amerikanischen magazins the atlantic
und er berichtet darin offenherzig über
seine angst störungen
ich habe mitgelitten also vor dem
traualtar vor panik fast zusammenbricht
habe herzhaft gelacht bei der
beschreibung wie er seine angst vor dem
erbrechen zu therapieren versucht und
ich habe mich ein bisschen ertappt
gefühlt also zum aberglauben als mittel
gegen angst kriegen und ich habe mich
gefragt wie kann man trotz so vieler
ängste so erfolgreich sein
wieso reden wir so selten über unsere
phobien wenn die meisten welche haben
und stimmt es dass angst und gerade
menschlich macht wie kirkegaard und
heidecker behaupten
einer der es wissen muss ist borwin
bandelow wurde berühmteste angstforscher
deutschlands und er ist heute mein gast
morgen herr bandelow gut morgen mikros
sind an kameras laufen nicht brennt
haben sie auch angst blödsinn zu reden
angst haben jetzt auch lustig zusammen
es erstaunt mich aber es ist ein sehr
mediengewandte angst therapeut sie
suchen die bühne
warum setzen sie sich denn diese angst
angst ich glaube wenn man gar keine
angst hätte dann will man auch keiner
guten sendung machen nicht also ein
bisschen lampenfieber muss ein
schauspieler haben oder auch dann
natürlich auch ein angstforscher
und angst ist ja sowieso ein antreibende
kraft nicht es gibt kaum ein kunstwerk
auch die wissenschaft die technik die
politik alles ist durch die angst
getrieben durch menschen die angst haben
nicht eine perfekte leistung abliefern
zu können und dadurch werden wir
eigentlich immer besser haben werden wir
die angst nicht hätten mögen war einfach
nur mittelmaß abliefern also einen
betablocker vor einer sendung zu nehmen
und aus loszuwerden ist keine gute idee
wurde als arzt und psychiater würdig
waren beta-blocker gegen angst zu nehmen
überhaupt auch natürlich keine
medikamente ein so schlimm ist es nicht
weil die angst mich ja auch gerade so
ein bisschen stimuliert recht ich würde
wahrscheinlich dass lahm war
langweiliges abliefern wenn ich das
nicht hätte und es stimmt ja aber schon
oder dass sie wissen die bühne suchen
sie sind ein bestseller autor nicht
einfach nur sicher sondern sie suchen
die bühne treten ja auch regelmäßig auf
als hot dog also nicht dass wurst im
teil besonders heiße arzt das wissen sie
ja ich habe eine band spielen soll dies
so beatles stones und bob dylan und so
weiter und wir machen ebenso auf
niedrigstem amateur niveau in getreten
war in kneipen auf und spielen dann mit
fünf leuten eben diese musik und ich bin
gitarrist und bassist in der band
ich finde ja ich darf auch singen aber
meine stimme ist so nicht so schön dass
ich also da bin ich davon also haben wir
über rock'n'roll sehen wo es nicht so
auf die schönheit ankommt dann haben sie
da auch lieber ja also gut bei manchen
stücken die kommen so aus dem bauch
heraus da muss man nicht mal drüber
nachdenken aber die haupt angst ist
eigentlich bei der musik dass man nicht
weiß welche stoffe als nächstes kommt
also die akkorde hat man alle im kopf
und melodien aber den abfolgen ist immer
das problem das ist so wie bei mir wenn
ich nicht weiß welche frage was nächste
wer jetzt wo die frage drehen wie sind
sie eigentlich angst forscher geworden
ja ich hatte und habe dann in der
ambulanz gearbeitet in einer klinik an
der uniklinik in götting und da waren 70
prozent der menschen die ebenso eine
ambulanz aufsuchen haben eben ängste
fast immer sind es panikattacken das ist
das häufigste was wir haben also
menschen die so mitten in der
fußgängerzone plötzlich anfälle kriegen
die tat rasen zittern schwitzen
schwindel und wissen nicht wo das
herkommen und denken dass irgendwie
medizinisch krank sind sind sie das
nicht
natürlich würde man sagen das ist auch
eine krankheit es ist eine krankheit
aber die entsteht eben nicht durch ein
kaputtes herz oder durch eine kaputte
lunge sondern das problem entsteht im
gehirn und es ist eigentlich eine kampf-
oder fluchtreaktion eigentlich eine ganz
normale reaktion denn wenn wir in ein
wenn ein tier oder ein lebewesen in
irgendeiner angst situation ist dann
passieren bestimmte sachen die das kann
man so vergleichen mit einem auto das
sich auf einen drohenden unfall
vorbereitet da werden also die
gurtstraffer angezogen die airbags
aufgeblasen und genau so ist es auch im
menschlichen körper
dass dann das herz schlägt schneller
damit mehr blut in die muskeln kommt
damit man schneller abbauen oder kämpfen
könnte oder auch die luftnot entsteht
dadurch dass mehr sauerstoff in die
lunge gepumpt wird auch um den
energiehaushalt zu verbessern damit man
eben für die für kampf oder flucht
vorbereitet ist und alle diese symptome
die man während einer panikattacke hat
hat sind eigentlich völlig normale
physiologische symptome die ihm nicht
gefährlich sind aber es wird von den
menschen natürlich jetzt als gefährlich
empfunden war ja überhaupt nicht weiß
warum passiert mir das jetzt in der
bahnhofstrasse in zürich irgendwo oder
aber auch die logische frage warum
passiert das wenn da gar kein ungeheuer
steht ja dass das ist genau muss man
sich so vorstellen dass da irgendein
warnzentrum im gehirn ist was folge vor
einer gefahr waren obwohl keine gefahr
da ist also dieser dieses thermostat ist
einfach zu empfindlich eingestellt warum
das so genau ist weiß man nicht es ist
ja so dass jeder fünfte schweizer
schweizerin erkrankt einmal im leben an
einer depression
die person an einer angststörung und das
können panikattacken sein das können
generalisierte angststörung sein oder
andere formen von angst ist denn das
verhältnis sowie viele menschen kriegen
denn so eine panikattacke
also man schätze es in sechs prozent
ungefähr aller menschen im leben an
einer panikstörung erkranken können
insgesamt alle erkannt angsterkrankungen
haben sie auch schon gesagt also
richtung 18 prozent und wenn man da die
von abdi nicht behandlungsbedürftig sind
also zum beispiel leute mit einer
spinnenphobie müssen nicht zum arzt
gehen wollen sie auch nicht dann bleibt
immer noch zwölf prozent übrig nicht und
panikstörungen sind die die haben heute
häufigsten zum arzt gehen aber es ist
nicht die häufigste angsterkrankungen
das ist die soziale phobie dass menschen
die also so eine krankhafte
schüchternheit haben dass sie immer
denken ich bin nichts wert ich bin ich
kann nicht gut reden ich sehe nicht gut
aus sowohl genau das gegenteil der fall
ist
wie also sich völlig unrealistisch
einschätzen aber die gehen nicht zum
arzt weil sie auch angst haben dass der
arzt sich auf die schenkel haut und
lacht und sagt hier was wollen sie denn
hier mit ein bisschen schüchternheit
müssen weil sie ja nicht behandeln so
ist es natürlich nicht die ärzte würden
auch dieses problem behandeln und wieso
nennen sie das kaum kraft könnte es
nicht auch einfach sein dass es menschen
geht die sind nun mal schüchtern die
kommen so auch ganz gut durchs leben
muss ja nicht jeder jetzt gegen die da
der partygänger sein
ja wenn man mal menschen fragt ein 60
prozent aller menschen würden zu geben
dass sie schüchtern sind wir müssen
natürlich nicht alle behandelt werden
aber es gibt eine gewisse grenze wo das
dann wird nicht krankhaft ist und das
ist das was wir soziale phobie nennen
weil das problem ist die fangen dann an
alkohol zu trinken also sagen wir mal
ungefähr hinter eben zweiten fall eines
alkoholismus steckt eine soziale phobie
das ein riesenproblem und es gibt eben
auch leute die sich wegen dieses
problems umbringen
das ist einer der häufigsten gründe für
so wie zieht man eben ständig denkt dass
man nichts wert ist und insofern kann
man dieses problem nicht einfach
bagatellisieren und sagen das ist gar
keine krankheit das ist einfach nur
schüchtern halt das muss man nicht
behandeln also das was wir solartag
sprache minderwertigkeitskomplexen ist
eine soziale phobie in ihrer
terminologie ja gut wir haben da so
kriterien für eine soziale phobie die
sind allerdings naturgemäß nicht so
besonders scharf da könnte man darüber
streiten ob wie man die genauer machen
kann
aber es steht halt eben den kriterien
drin das ist wirklich das leben
beeinflussen muss in negativer form
erst dann würde man von einer krankheit
sprechen wenn man sagt ein bisschen
schüchtern ist es ja eine eine angenehme
eigenschaft mann würde sagen
bescheidenheit ist eine zier doch weiter
kommt man ohne ihr also das wird
eigentlich auch wirklich gesellschaft
sehr schüchternen gelobt und geschätzt
weil sie eben zurückhaltend sind und ich
nicht so penetrant in der
außendarstellung insofern ist es auch
eine angenehme eigenschaft aber für die
schwer betroffenen ist es wirklich ein
echtes problem haben sie vorhin gesagt
der leidensdruck spielt eigentlich eine
rolle bei der beurteilung ob das jetzt
eine krankheit ist oder nicht nehmen
jetzt mal an ich wäre der festen
überzeugung bananen zu essen ist
unglaublich gefährlich ich wäre sofort
sterben wenn ich eine banane hesse ich
habe eine phobie vor bananen aber ich
komme ganz gut das leben weil ich muss
ja keine bananen essen dann würden sie
sagen dass ich nicht
behandlungsbedürftig ist auch nicht
krankhaft sondern soweit eigentlich weiß
ich nicht darunter leide
ja es gibt ja so viele einfache vorgehen
also ein typus typisch ist die
spinnenphobie also 50 prozent der
deutschen wahrscheinlich auch der
schweizer haben einer spinnenphobie
obwohl die exemplare praktisch nichts
machen können sie können nicht beißen
stechen oder kratzen
man kann also gar keine schlechten
erfahrungen mit spinnen gemacht haben
und man kommt durchs leben
manche können nicht in den keller gehen
müssen dann den ehemann schicken um bier
zu holen aber also ich habe mal in einer
fernsehsendung hat man mir die gemeinde
rot knie vogelspinne mal auf die hand
gesetzt und ich hatte ein riesen schiss
also die moderatorin hat gesagt herr
professor sie müssen sich doch sie sagen
doch ihren patienten immer sie müssen
sich der angst aussetzen
und hier ist die spinne ich und hat man
mir die dann einfach auf die hand
gesetzt ich konnte mich nicht wehren
waren eine live-sendung und ich hatte
ein riesen schuss aber danach waren die
spinnenphobie vorbei und habe dann in
einer späteren sendung war sechs jahre
später habe ich nochmal genau die
gleiche spinne gekriegt hieß clara und
habe sie dann einer einer tagesschau
gaddafi dann auch auf die hand gesetzt
also darüber und auch die hat dann durch
diesen einen versuch ihre spinnenphobie
verloren nicht also ist ganz erstaunlich
vielleicht man das behandeln kann also
es ist eigentlich immer die exposition
mit der angst dass man dann die angst
dann verliert man also man kann gerade
die einfachen probieren schnell
verlieren also zb ihre bananen phobie
dann würde ich aber ich würde sie voll
stoffen mit einer dann würde das also in
wenigen stunden weg gehen und was ist
jetzt mit zu ihr sagen wir warm
vorstellung die man haben kann immer
noch nicht glauben daran dass dieser
ganze raum hier voller blaue elefanten
steckt dass die aber nichts machen
solange ich das wort ameise nicht sagen
ja gut das ist jetzt eine ausgefallene
phobie die es mir jetzt noch nicht
untergekommen nicht also es könnte das
klingt schon fast wie eine psychotische
angst die sie schildern also es gibt
natürlich auch ängste die ihr aus dem
bereich der angsterkrankungen
herausgehen das ist wer zum beispiel
also menschen mit schizophrenie haben
auch ängste massive links also dass sie
zum beispiel verfolgt werden bespitzelt
werden beobachtet werden nicht aber das
ist eine ganz andere
normalerweise nichts mit gangs
erkrankungen zu tun sie haben ja sehr
viele patienten auch behandelt gab es
nur eine ausstellung wo sie irgendwann
das handtuch werfen musste
es gibt schon leute die wirklich extrem
schwer krank sind die eben auch gar
nicht aus dem haus gehen und auch selbst
das haben wir dann häufig gemeldet nicht
also erst mal war das problem dass wir
gar nicht zu uns gekommen sind dann hab
ich dann erstmal mit der post eine
tablette verschickt die also eine
beruhigungstablette und dann in der
hoffnung dass der patient die dann nimmt
und dann vielleicht mit anderen personen
an zu mir kommt das hat in vielen fällen
geholfen aber es gibt eben auch ein paar
leute die sind nicht gekommen und dann
konnte ich dann gar nichts machen
aber diejenigen die zu ihnen gekommen
sind sind alle gehälter von haien
ritterrede selbst schade eigentlich
ungern wir können ängste unterdrücken so
dass man sie nicht mehr spürt aber so
heilen können wir eigentlich nicht also
wir können einfach nur immerhin war
alles besser machen und zwar so gut dass
die leute völlig zufrieden sind
aber reden ungern von haien das klingt
ein bisschen übertrieben
jetzt sagen sie die menschen sind dann
zufrieden wenn sie die angst
unterdrücken können also ganz weg geht
die offenbar nicht man kann sich gleich
gegen mit exposition bisschen überwinden
gleichzeitig haben sie am anfang des
gesprächs etwas gesagt wie wir brauchen
die angst um angetrieben zu sein sie
sagen haben auch an einer stelle in
ihrem angst buch angst ist das super
benzin des erfolgs also was jetzt kommt
da drücken oder angst davor
es gibt ja verschiedene arten von ängste
dass einmal gibt es die realen ängste
das ist die ängste dass das uns
irgendwas passieren könnte wenn wir die
nicht hätten dann würden wir uns im auto
nicht anschnallen und hätten dauern
durch unfälle und dann gibt es aber auch
diese völlig übertriebenen ängste vor
spinnen oder fußgängerzonen das ist das
was ich behandle und dann gibt es aber
auch letztendlich so eine form von
sozialer angst nämlich die angst dass
man nicht nichts
perfektes abliefert und das ist
eigentlich eine sehr wichtige angst das
ist das was ich meinte wenn man sagte
angst ist der raketen motor für erfolg
dass man wenn man irgend eine großartige
leistungen erbringen möchte in der kunst
in der musik in der wissenschaft im
sport dann es ganz gut dass in angst zu
haben also da gibt es auch so ein jörg
stolzen gesetz das besagt das ist so
eine uförmige kurve ja gar keine angst
hat er hat auch keine leistung wäre ein
mittleres angst level hat er eine hohe
leistung und wer dann wieder extreme
angst hat der wird so gelähmt das ja
auch wieder keine leistung erbringen
kann also am besten ist es das sage ich
immer fußballtrainern sie müssen ihre
jungs zusammen oder ein mittleres angst
level setzen damit sie die
weltmeisterschaft wenn sie nicht im
fußball als beispiel ich dachte gerade
an die angst des torwarts vor dem
elfmeter auch wenn er zu viel angst hat
man geht ja auch glenn gould der torwart
hat gar keine angst vorm elfmeter weil
ja ja weiß geht sowieso rein
deswegen hatte davor weniger angst von
einer hört natürlich denkt ich habe gar
keine chance aber ich nutze sie und
deswegen gelingt es auch ab und zu mal
wieder zu erwarten dass zu dieser bälle
zu fangen ich glaube die tour weiter
mehr angst vor diesen ganz normalen
beeilen die rein gehen also am
schlimmsten ist ja wenn das ein ganz
einfacher einfach zu halten der ball ist
und er geht rein das ist das schlimmste
für den privat aber noch einmal die
angst also ein bisschen angst oder der
haben aber ich nehme jetzt mal an im
fußball gibt es auch strategien angst
loszuwerden
sonst kann man wahrscheinlich mehr
richtig kicken ja ich glaube es ist eine
bestimmte
das sind bestimmte leute die das machen
können wir können nicht völlig ängstlich
und sensibel sein aber man hat ja auch
immer wieder von fußballern die unter
angsterkrankungen oder depressionen
leiden immer wieder steht das in der
presse
also das ist gerade die richtige
mischung wer also völlig nur dumm stark
und wasserdicht ist der kann
wahrscheinlich auch nicht ein guter
sportler sein weil er war immer denkt
ich habe sowieso alles und wir arbeiten
nicht an sich diese zusammenhang
zwischen angst und erfolgte es ja
wirklich einer der immer wieder
beschrieben wird
es gibt auch ganz berühmte beispiele
newton war ein extremer vbk einstein
thomas hobbes darwin leute die zum teil
fast monatelang nicht aus dem haus ging
weil sie so große ängste haben aber auch
schauspieler wie hugh grant zum beispiel
ist ein angst patient noch einmal zu
diesem zu diesem zusammenhang könnte man
fast schon sagen wenn man jetzt erzogen
wird man muss den kindern ein bisschen
aufmachen oder sie ein bisschen unter
druck setzen damit diese unter spannung
da mal aufhört und die angst kurzem
wissen ansteigt aber ist das kann
einfluss der erziehung auf die angst ist
relativ geringen also eltern denken
immer dass dass sie das in irgendeiner
form steuern könnten dass sie erkennt
ängstlich oder weniger ängstlich
erzielen können insofern es ist gott sei
dank nicht so dass die mutter dann
überhaupt die möglichkeit hat angst zu
machen natürlich in gewissem maße kann
man schon kindern wie sagen wo es lang
geht aber die wissenschaft ist ein
bisschen davon abgekommen immer die
erziehung als den hauptgrund
zu sehen wie ängste entstehen nicht also
es ist eben so dass ängste auch
entstehen durch vererbung und dass er
ein die einflussmöglichkeit erziehung
relativ gering ist sind ja gut also
es wurde früher überstrapaziert dass die
mutterbindung wichtig ist und werden ihn
nicht hat der kriegt angststörungen
dagegen spricht eben die forschung dass
das eben
es hat natürlich einen einfluss aber da
ist viel geringer als man angenommen hat
mein computer hat mal ausgerechnet dass
die ja vier erziehung fünf prozent
ausmacht vom ganzen kuchen also dass
viele angriff aktoren da viel wichtiger
sind als wir ihn jetzt alle die
gestressten eltern gerne
trotzdem gab es diese debatte um die so
genannte tiger man diese
us-amerikanische gleichzeitig
chinesische wissenschaftlerin die ihre
kinder mit einem rigiden
erziehungsprogramm zu höchstleistungen
antreibt und in ihrem letzten buch der
triple pack kitsch sagt sie angst ist
ein faktor letztendlich um erfolgreich
zu sein und wenn man dieses buch von
news corp stoßen liest über die angst
kriegt man ja auch ein bisschen den
eindruck
wie schafft man es denn also noch einmal
dieses buch da hat einer angststörung
diesem die man sich vorstellen kann sich
das kopflosen hat vor allem angst und
trotzdem ist der chefredakteur eines
extrem renommierten us-amerikanischen
magazins nämlich die atlantic wie
schafft man das
wir hoffen dass patienten arrangieren
ihr leben um die angst herum was man
natürlich kann man nur vor waren also
mann soll dann nicht warum ist hängt das
an wie man jetzt zur arbeit kommt mit
dem auto oder zu fuß oder so nicht weil
dir vor allem angst haben zum beispiel
auch mit dem auto zu fahren nicht dann
kommen sie ins haus und nehmen nicht den
fahrstuhl sondern
laufen zwölf stockwerke den treppe hoch
und das ist das was wir unseren
patienten raten weil sie nicht machen
sollen aber es gibt viele menschen die
schaffen es wirklich um sich um die
angst herum zu arrangieren und
verzichten dann auf unglaublich viele
dinge und was dann kriegen dann
irgendwann raus dass das was sie am
besten können eigentlich von ihrem
schreibtisch zu sitzen und irgendwelche
bücher zu schreiben da können sie völlig
vor angst frei leben gibt es keine
spinnen keine fahrstühle nichts und weil
sie auch diese zeit haben weil sie
verschiedene freizeitbeschäftigung
einfach nicht wahrnehmen wie sport weil
das ja gefährlich sein könnte nicht also
eigentlich werden sie dann zur sozialen
phobie kann genau das heißt diese beiden
zum beispiel auch soziale kontakte viele
berühmte menschen haben eben soziale
phobie gehabt auch bill gates oder
warren buffett die beiden reichsten
männer der welt also man kann auch
schweine reich werden mit der sozialen
phobie oder es gibt eben auch so
beispiel von schauspielern sehr viele
schauspieler robert de niro oder
michelle pfeiffer oder nicole kidman jim
carrey das waren alles leute die große
angst hatten unter leute zu gehen und
die haben quasi ihre angst vor leuten
damit begründet dass sie hässlich dumm
und unattraktiv sind und haben gesagt ja
jetzt muss ich ein schauspieler werden
und dann dann kann ich ja meine theorie
mir selbst widerlegen dass ich so
unansehnlich und unattraktiv bin ist das
eigentlich dann die exposition der
schauspieler ja gut das unterschiedlich
die die es geschafft haben die anderen
die es nicht geschafft haben und dann
stille heimliche trinker geworden sind
von denen redet keiner nicht aber es
gibt eben doch die die besonders gut
waren und das wirklich der manchmal
schaut welche schauspieler wirklich
nachhaltig wie tom hanks über 22 jahre
immer wieder genommen für filme oder
robert de niro dessen eben menschen die
eben diese
sehr starke soziale angst hatten aber
könnte man sagen die schauspielerei ist
die exposition therapie für diese
menschen aber sind sie ängstlich in das
ich immer wieder vor die kamera gehen
schaffen sie sich wieder sich zu
exponieren ja genau es ist ja auch so
angst die menschen mit der sozialen
phobie haben angst emotionen
darzustellen also wie liebe also wir
können zum beispiel jemand anders nicht
sagen ich liebe dich das ist sehr
schwierig für sie aber sie können auch
nicht sagen ich hasse dich das ist
können ihre gefühle nicht offen zeigen
und wenn sie dann schauspieler sind dann
darf man ja so was alles sagen und kann
nachher sagen ja ich hab das ja die
schauspieler ich war ja dafür
eingestellt und habe mein geld dafür
gekriegt nicht und so können sie also
wirklich sehr gut extrem gut sogar
emotionen zeigen im kino aber wenn sie
dann wieder zu hause mit ihrer gattin
sind dann zeigen sie jetzt dort nicht
dass ihnen die eigentlich bei woody
allen der ja einer der berühmtesten
neurotiker überhaupt ist und bei dem man
bei jedem 10 wieder den eindruck hat er
arbeitet seine angst ab ich möchte gerne
mit ihnen zusammen ein ausschnitt
schauen aus hannah und ihre schwestern
da spielt woody allen die person mickey
1 comedy autor der dauernd angst hat zu
versorgen und er geht wegen eines höher
problems zum arzt und glaubt danach er
hätte an hirntumor
[Musik]
die menschen hier haben wir ja das ist
ein großes problem bei uns dann auch das
wäre sehr viele patienten haben geben so
eine krankheitsangst haben also die
wesen sich krankheiten ein und jeden tag
überlegen so dass sie krebs haben können
oder jetzt irgendwelche dinge und danach
man tests und versuchte es ihnen
auszureden indem man irgendwie
laborbefunde vorlegt aber sie glauben es
nicht weil das ist wir haben ja dieses
angst systeme im gegnern was auf einem
sehr primitiven level ist es hat also
keinen hochschulabschluss und das kann
man nicht einfach durch laborwerte
überzeugen dass vernunft gehört schon
längst kapiert dass alles in ordnung ist
aber dieses system was ja verrückt
spielt das redet ein weiter angst ein
dass man
eine krankheit hatten und ja das ist
eigentlich ganz gut die schauspieler
also dass egal wie einmal andere
menschen reagieren oder wie ärzte
reagieren dass immer so ins negative
gedreht wird
vor ungefähr zehn jahren hat man
behauptet man hätte das woody allen
gehen entdeckt die pmg ich weiß nicht
wahrscheinlich woody allen hat es sicher
habe war einer der den träger aber ich
habe das noch nicht gehört nicht aber
ich denke dass er da spielt das ist auch
zum teil seine eigene person er ist
wirklich ein stadtneurotiker nicht also
wirklich ein mensch der soziale phobie
hat er hat auch natürlich wahrscheinlich
auch krankheitsangst mal gehabt also das
ist sehr weit verbreitet haben das ja
auch wirklich bei dem kleinen vielen
kleinigkeiten dann denkt das ist ganz
schlimm ist und dann gleich zum arzt
drin nicht als ich wahrscheinlich dann
auch ein bisschen selbst gespürt denke
ich mal jetzt mal ganz ehrlich herr
bandelow auf das angeguckt haben muss
mir ja beide lachen
die situation wo sie auf sicher auch ein
bisschen machen müssen
gut ich lache manchmal mit meinen
patienten ist nicht so dass ich dann
also weiter bis der patient hier raus
ist und dann entscheiden das gericht
aber nein aber man kann ja auch die
angst auch mit humor behandeln mich also
viele angstpatienten finden das jetzt
nicht gerade lustig wenn sie
irgendwelche schwerwiegende ängste
schirm und ihre ehefrauen und ihre
freundinnen immer darüber lachen aber
man kann über angst bessere witze machen
als über depressionen nein das ist ja
gut also angst wird sofern jetzt hatte
ich so spontan ist kein aber
viele menschen diese vor bienen haben
merkwürdige phobien können eigentlich
irgendwie auch selber darüber lachen
denn jeder mensch hat ein vernünftiges
gehirn was wahrscheinlich uns rennt
frontalhirn sitzt und dann ein
angstzentrum war es weiter hinten im
gehirn sitzt und was sehr sehr einfach
gestrickt ist nicht sie können
tatsächlich lachen mit ihrem vernunft
gehirn über dieses verrückte huhn was
hat diese angstsymptome in ihrem kopf
produziert aber manchmal kommen sie eben
nicht dagegen an warum ist das so weil
dieses system obwohl ist ja so sowohl
dumm und ungebildet ist ist in ein
wirkungsgeschichte der menschen oder
tiere ebenso wichtig gewesen für das
überleben das ist immer ein sieg bringt
über das bildungssystem nicht das
erhoffte szenen ist eigentlich der
schwächste teil von dem ganzen gehirn
also wir haben ja sagen wir mal drei
systeme im gehirn einmal das
belohnungssystem das ist das was für
essen und sex belohnt ich will fressen
saufen und guten sex und zwar sofort
dass das belohnungssystem
das macht die positiven gefühle und dann
gibt es immer dass angst ist der sagt es
ist verboten das ist schwierig das ist
teuer das ist gefährlich und davon
können kinder kommen also die dieses
system arbeitet immer gegen das
belohnungssystem moment bleibt noch dass
vernunft system muss versuchen zwischen
den beiden zu vermitteln
ja natürlich das system extrem wichtig
machen wir einen einen schritt weiter
zur gesellschaftlichen dimensionen der
angst im moment gibt es ein buch das
heißt diskutiert wird von heinz bude
einem deutschen soziologen gesellschaft
der arzt gesagt wir sind eine
gesellschaft der angst nun gibt es immer
wieder diese attribute waren auch schon
risikogesellschaft die waren schon eine
müdigkeit gesellschaft jetzt sind wir
eine gesellschaft der angst aber er
zeigt sich relativ überzeugen dass
unsere gesellschaft brüchig geworden ist
durch diese ganzen die durch
kapitalisierung der gesellschaft kann
man das nennen
durch den eindruck von unsicherheiten
das wegbrechen von familienstrukturen
zum teil
ist es denn so haben angst
angststörungen zugenommen
nein das wird immer wieder behauptet
also ich mache ja sehr viele interviews
zu angst und die erste frage ist immer
es stimmt doch dass die an störungen in
den letzten jahren zugenommen haben sagt
geben wir hier in den letzten zwei
jahren fünf jahren zehn jahren mir ist
nichts davon bekannt nicht und es gibt
sogar wissenschaftliche untersuchungen
die zeigen dass es gar nicht so ist und
wir angsterkrankungen sind ja zum teil
ja auch genetisch bedingt also 50 60
prozent genetisch das heißt sie nämlich
in fünf jahren zu
auch nicht in zehn jahren auch nicht in
100 jahren also sie bleiben
wahrscheinlich über die jahrtausende
immer gleich genau wie die menschen auch
immer eine leber haben und es auch immer
so sein wird
und diese angst zu erkrankungen sind ja
auch im rahmen der entwicklung das sind
ja sogar auswüchse von wichtigen ängsten
die in der entwicklungsgeschichte der
menschen wichtig waren
also werden diese angst störungen auch
nie ausgerottet werden und ich glaube
auch nicht dass die gesellschaften sich
ständig ändern wenn ich das heute
betrachte man kommt ja als als
angstforscher durch über die ganze durch
die ganze welt wenn man in südafrika
oder schweden oder tokio ist dann findet
man nicht dass die menschen
unterschiedlich angst haben sondern die
ängste sind egal in jeder kultur und
jeder gesellschaft gleich und so ist es
auch wirklich jahrhundert gewesen aber
immerhin sagt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation dass die
angststörung die depression überholt hat
es ist jetzt eigentlich die am meisten
auftretende psychische erkrankung und
das sei nicht immer so gewesen
ja also die einzigen statistiken die ich
kenne diesen usa gemacht worden und
dessen die einzigen verlässlichen die
die haben das wiederholt im abstand von
mehreren jahrzehnten und da kam aus
keinen unterschied waren da waren damals
schon die angststörung immer
also schon vorne an die waren schon
eigentlich immer wenn man auch alte
berichte liest von aus dem 16
jahrhundert da wurden auch die
panikstörungen und soziale phobie wurden
beschrieben genauso wie es heute ist
aber es tatsächlich zur an störungen
sind die häufigsten psychischen
erkrankungen sind also weit vor den
depressionen nach also wenn sie das
kritisch sehen dass ausstellungen
zugenommen haben dann lassen sie uns
gleich doch über den punkt sprechen was
heißt eigentlich gesellschaftliche angst
und wie geht das individuum um mit
diesen formen der ängste sie haben jetzt
ja viel über phobien gesprochen spinnen
bananen panikattacken
aber dieses gefühl nicht zu genügen
dieses gefühl in einem hamsterrad zu
sitzen stichwort auch borderline-syndrom
menschen die sich nicht mehr richtig
binden können sich nach bindung sehen es
gibt die wunderbaren bücher von der
soziologin eva illouz die auch bei
darüber berichtet wie die beziehungen
durch den kapitalismus sich verändert
haben ist eigentlich alles dauernd
evaluiert kosten nutzen erwägungen
spielen plötzlich eine rolle an orten wo
wir früher verlässlichkeit hatten
vertrauen hatten
da versteht man doch eigentlich dass man
den eindruck hat die gesellschaft
insgesamt oder die menschen in dieser
gesellschaft werden längst nicht jammern
werden haben in deutschland ein großes
feldexperiment nämlich die
wiedervereinigung richter gab es
menschen geben aus deutschland gelebt
haben wo alles reglementiert war und da
hat man tatsächlich bei vielen leuten
also wir haben ja in göttingen
zehn kilometer von dieser ehemaligen
grenze gewohnt und dann kamen eben doch
sehr viele menschen aus ostdeutschland
um sich auch wegen ängsten behandeln zu
lassen
dabei habe ich eben festgestellt ist die
eine sache total gleich ist dass die
panikstörung euer die gleichen waren in
der ehemaligen ddr und in
westdeutschland aber das natürlich jetzt
neue ängste entstanden sie sind zum
beispiel man musste sich damals keine
sorgen um versicherungen machen oder um
steuern und viele viele dinge hat der
staat einfach für ein gemacht und dann
plötzlich stammhalter vor der wahl muss
muss sich auslegen welche für aussuchen
welche versicherungen mache ich denn
jetzt und welche ich habe jetzt die
auswahl zwischen 256 käsesorten und muss
überall eine wahl treffen und darüber
nachdenken über handy tarife dass das
macht vielen menschen angst und vor
allem menschen die also es gewohnt waren
dass ihnen alles gemacht werden für die
ist es schon eine echte umstellung und
gerade die ältere personen waren davon
sehr betroffen und haben das so gar
nicht aushalten können diese diese
plötzlich viel freiheit die sie hatten
in dieser beziehung aber bei jungen hat
mal gesehen dass ich es genossen haben
und das dass sie sich auch schnell damit
zurecht gefunden haben
sie sprechen jetzt von der angst vor den
realen freiheiten die entstehen den
möglichkeiten auch das ist ja so eine
idee auch bei bude zum beispiel dieses
dauernd sich entwerfen müssen die vielen
optionen muss die options- gesellschaft
gibt es ja auch noch
es ist aber auch in der philosophie
eigentlich eine ganz alte debatte am
stark angeleitet von sören kierkegaard
aufgenommen dann von heidecker bis hin
zu sagte den existenzialisten dass die
menschliche freiheit etwas ist was uns
unglaublich angst macht kann sie das
gehört ja auch angst
sozusagen als angefangen denn die
verbindung zwischen angst und freiheit
er hat ihm sehr viel sorgen gemacht ich
glaube kirche corvair einer meiner
lieblings patienten gewesen er hat ja
sehr viel sehr brauch unter ängsten und
depressionen gelitten nicht und das ist
tatsächlich so dass eben freiheit eben
auch angst machen kann und daraus dürfen
wir aber natürlich nicht die konsequenz
ziehen dass wir die gesellschaft in
richtung unfreiheit wieder für hin
verändern sollten auf keinen fall ne es
ist nicht es wird also was ich ein
bisschen kritisiere an solchen
soziologischen überlegungen dass diese
gesellschaft sich jetzt jedes jahr
wieder neu verändert und alles völlig
anders weiß es wird einmal zum beispiel
davon geredet dass heute mehr stress ist
als früher ist überlege ich als ich ein
kind war war da denn kein stress also da
standen atomkrieg im raum nicht also die
russen haben gedruckt uns anzugreifen
und kubakrise gab es nicht also das war
jetzt nicht gerade stress 2 kurz nachdem
wir einen weltkrieg überstanden hatten
kommt dann so eine phase wo wir von
einem erneuten weltkrieg bedroht werden
das war viel schlimmer die bedrohung
also irgend eine bedrohung die es heute
gibt
ich glaube nicht dass es stress weiter
reisen aber die bedrohung galt der
gesellschaft
das kündigungsschreiben betrug sie als
individuum jährlich ein eminenter
unterschied ja klar aber es ist ja auch
nicht so dass wir sagen wir mal ständig
also mehr probleme mit kündigungen haben
als als damals oder so alt sondern der
druck im beruf war sich ja auch früher
noch stärker als als heute und jetzt
rede ich von deutschland
der schweizer ist jetzt ähnlich sein wir
haben jetzt gerade so eine wunderbare
beschäftigung dass man also nicht davon
reden kann dass es jetzt gerade schlecht
ist die arbeitsmarktsituation wir waren
noch nie so gut aber es gibt natürlich
ländern länder wie griechenland oder
spanien wo die leute massiv durch sowas
bedroht werden ich und dass das macht
den leuten wirklich angst und das trägt
sie auch nicht also das ist das ist aber
jetzt nicht mehr entwicklung
das ist nicht so dass diese menschen mit
panikattacken zum psychiater laufen die
jetzt in griechenland leben aber das
leben ist nicht gut die machen sehr
viele sorgen wenn wir noch einmal bei
dieser kirkegaard angst bleiben da geht
es ja nicht nur darum dass man jetzt
sind mehr bedrohungen im raum sondern
das leben an sich ist ein leben in angst
und eigentlich ist es die ganz
wesentliche science form des menschen
ängstlich zu sein das gehört zu unserer
zusage und entwerfen müssen jetzt haben
sie vorhin gesagt sie hätten gerne
kirkegaard therapiert er hat sich selber
therapiert indem er gläubig wurde also
seine lösung war der glaube wenn sie
dann gute lösung
ich habe mein fahrer gefragt ob das so
ist das eigentlich in seiner gemeinde
alle menschen angst frei sind meint er
ist genau das gegenteil
er hatte sehr viel
um eine mitglieder die auch in wohnungen
werden und vielleicht deswegen weil sie
verstärkt unter ängsten leiden auch das
heil in der religion suchen
also für mich ist religion auch eine
maßnahme des belohnungssystem zu
steigern zu stimulieren es gibt ja
dieses belohnungssystem was über
endorphine wirkt und alles was mit
religion zu tun hat kann eben diese
endorphine anheben das ist so der
gegenspieler des systems so dass man
theoretisch schon erklären könnte wie
religion einem angst nehmen kann es gibt
auch wirklich leute aber wir müssen
schon sehr sehr gläubig sein ihr relativ
elegant angstfrei durchs leben können
weil sie gut glauben aber individuum der
jetzt nicht so den starken glauben hat
wo ich mich auch zu rechnen würde dann
würde das nichts nützen ich kann mir
jetzt nicht vornehmen ich glaube jetzt
mal und nicht gegeben sonntag beten und
dann habe ich bin ich angst weil es
funktioniert nur bei leuten die dazu
geboren sind also dass das kann kann man
sich jetzt nicht vornehmen nein das ist
ein gegenspieler aber es ist nicht so
gerade man hat das auch mal untersucht
zum beispiel auch beten hilft gegen
psychiatrische erkrankungen da kam
nichts raus nicht oder auch es gibt ja
auch religiöse psychiater nicht und
jetzt mal gefragt würden sie denn
schizophrenie mit beeten behandeln oder
mit medikamenten und 95 prozent haben
gesagt mit medikamenten also von den
religiösen psychiater es ist also schon
so dass religion sehr viel
gucken kann wie man so schön sagt was
allgemeine lebensangst angeht aber nicht
in der form dass man sich das mal
vornehmen kann und jetzt mal sagt ich
werde man gläubig ich bin immer noch ein
bisschen hängengeblieben und ihre an
ihrem widerspruch dass die gesellschaft
ängstlicher wird zumindest habe ich den
eindruck wenn man miteinander spricht in
der mensa am abend ein bier kriegt man
ja schon von sehr sehr vielen menschen
zu hören dass sie ihm gestresster sind
dass sie sich unter druck fühlen dass
sie angst haben gleich jetzt nicht
gleich den arbeitsplatz zu verlieren
aber ich glaube sehr viele menschen in
meiner umgebung zumindest haben sehr
viel mehr angst nicht die leistung zu
bringen als dies früher der fall war
wenn sie sagen na ja das ist nicht
wirklich eine verbreitung jetzt der an
störungen sondern wir sind einfach alle
verweichlicht geworden haben uns mal der
komfortzone heraus uns gemütlich machen
wollen und wenn die haut es hat nicht
sein wenn ich glaube ich beobachte das
ja schon seit über 8 20 jahre und das
wird eigentlich in jedem jahr wird das
so gesagt das ist jetzt gerade in den
letzten jahren schlimmer geworden ist
und jetzt im moment ist es so ja dass
man ständig auch erreichbar ist durch
die hände ist das würde den stress
allgemein so verstärken und früher man
das will oder anderen voraussetzungen
gesagt dass da war uns die telefone oder
so die gab es ja früher irgendwann auch
nicht nicht das ist eigentlich immer ein
jammern auf hohem niveau sagen jeder
sagt eigentlich
ist immer mehr gestresst und das war vor
30 jahren genauso und 50 jahren genauso
aber man hat den eindruck das ist jetzt
gerade stärker geworden ist und gerade
erfolgreiche leute das sind ja auch
wahrscheinlich treffen sie sich sie
haben mit sehr vielen erfolgreichen
leuten und die sind natürlich die setzen
sich teilweise selbst unter druck indem
sie sich viel zu viel vornehmen aber
nachher dann auch viele positive dinge
davon erfahren aber trotzdem merken sie
dass sie auch im zeit- und termindruck
kommen und dass ich mir bei den
mutationen gesellschaft die so vielen
möglichkeiten die wir haben
ehrenberg ein anderer soziologie ein
französische soziologe
er spricht von diesem ermüdeten selbst
dieses diese gefahr dass man sich
einfach verläuft in dem bestreben sein
leben zu entwerfen man muss ja dauernd
was werden wir sind ja nichts mehr genau
dass man man hat immer das gefühl wenn
ich das nicht mache und gehen das nicht
mache dann verpasse ich irgendwas und
das was ich bin da so ein bisschen von
abgekommen ist also wenn ich jetzt
anfragen kriege für fernseher noch
untersagt ich da manchmal auch das
schaffe ich nicht aber ich gerade im
urlaub früher weil ich dann aus dem
urlaub dahin gerast und so weiter
[Gelächter]
natürlich aber man muss nicht immer
alles mitmachen ich also es gibt so
einen spruch den ich mir sage
vereinfache dein leben und das heißt
also man muss nicht immer alles
mitgemacht haben weil man immer denkt
man verpasst war es nicht also es gibt
ich glaube wir sind eine gesellschaft
von leuten die denken sie verpassen
immer alles das ist glaube ich das
hauptproblem in unserer gesellschaft ich
verpasse diese partie oder dieses
treffen mit diesem wichtigen leuten oder
diesen wichtigen geschäftstermin
verpasse ich und die wollen das dann
trotzdem machen und irgendwann merken
sie das ist zwar alles toll diese
termine aber letztendlich bin ich da
habe ich mich dadurch auch unter druck
und angst gesetzt und unter
leistungsdruck wenn wir noch einmal zur
gesellschaft zurückgehen gibts im moment
auch die große debatte über die ganze
xenophobie also immer angst vor dem
fremden stichwort peggy da diese angst
vor der sogenannten islamisierung der
gesellschaft
wie schätzen sie das sein hast du
genommen ja wir haben ja deutschland
beobachtet das ist eben so genannte päda
demonstrationen geben gibt wo er dann
wirklich auch bis zu 10.000 menschen in
einer stadt dann auflaufen und dann
gegen die islamisierung des abendlandes
demonstrieren was ich gerade mit freude
gelesen habe dass in frankfurt das ist
ja eine stadt mit ungefähr 30 prozent
ausländeranteil dass dazu der pegi
demonstration ganz 69 leute erschienen
waren und dafür 1000 gegendemonstranten
also dass offensichtlich so dass das
nicht überall in deutschland ist und als
auch so dass sich das verläuft und das
wird ein paar wochen sich völlig
verlaufen haben der gilt das war mal so
eine phase ich glaube das kann eine
gewisse xenophobie in jedem menschen
angelegt ist nicht das war kommt aus
einer zeit als er noch in stämmen gelebt
haben und da muss man sich verteidigen
gegen andere stimmen weil stämme weil
die nahrung knapp war
man hat sich also gegenseitig die
nahrung weg nehmen müssen um zu
überleben und nur die die stärksten
haben dann überlegt und man musste ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl machen auch wenn man
den nachbarn gar nicht so gut leiden
konnte wenn man mit ihm zusammen gegen
die anderen stämme in den krieg gezogen
ist dann wartet mal war mal der beste
kumpel
diese hat sich also ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl ergeben aber b auch
so eine xenophobie und nur die stimme
die das auch ein bisschen hatten
überlebt und deswegen braucht es heute
einfach nur einen demagogen irgendeinem
menschen der den menschen also der
die leute ein bisschen aus der reserve
lockt um diese xenophobie wieder
aufleben zu lassen nicht weil die leute
sind da anfällig nicht das haben wir in
deutschland gesehen in der nazizeit das
von dem einfachen menschen bis zum
universitätsprofessor alle sich von
diesem demagogen habe überzeugen lassen
manipulieren lassen und das fürchte
jetzt kommen kann immer wieder passieren
dass eben diese menschen angelegte zeno
phobie dann durch solche demagogen
angeheizt wird vielleicht ist eigentlich
schwierigkeit ja auch sie haben jetzt
gesagt gemeinschaften die haben dann
eben als kehrseite dieser xenophobischen
elemente man kann sich auch fragen wie
wie gestalten sich eigentlich
gemeinschaften sie können sich berufen
auf werte nach innen was ich das
gemeinsam wird von oder nach außen in
abgrenzung und wenn wir vielleicht ein
stück weit vergessen was uns
zusammenhält im positiven sinne beginnen
wir nach außen zu schießen könnten nicht
dass auch in sendungen sein dass herr
schwanken gebiete der gesellschaft das
irgendwie nicht mehr so sehr mag seine
werte hochzuhalten deswegen in
abgrenzung neue werte zu schaffen sucht
ja da sind wir immer wenn ein diktator
innere probleme im land hat sei es
wirtschaft oder andere probleme dann
versucht er das volk auf andere weise
zusammen zu schweißen indem er ihm
erzählt dass man einen sehr großen feind
von außen hat der us amerikanische
präsident franklin roosevelt hat 19 33
zur zeit der großen depression in seiner
antrittsrede damals gesagt habt keine
angst vor der angst oder das einzige
wovor wir uns wirklich fürchten müssen
ist die angst und er hat eigentlich
damit glaube ich vor allem sagen wollen
was wir brauchen ist so was wie ein reh
an einen realismus der angst also das
rechnen mit der angst damit sie eben
nicht instrumentalisiert werden kann
weil angst ist immer schon da
wir müssen sie nicht fürchten wir müssen
sie vielleicht einfach ernst nehmen und
gestalten
marie curie hat gesagt wir müssen keine
angst haben wir müssen nur alles der
stehen also
die angst versteht wie sie entsteht dann
ist das schon mal die halbe miete dann
kann man auch dagegen angehen
das ist ganz wichtiger punkt möchte das
wäre wenn man das informiert ist über
die das wesen der angst dann
hat mal eher angst jetzt wissen sie mir
noch etwas erklären nämlich den
kugelschreiber in an einer stelle in
ihrem buch geht es auch darum dass wir
oft sehr irrational sind in mehreren
ängsten also stichwort angst vor dem
terrorismus die gefahr bei einem
terroristischen attentat ums leben zu
kommen nicht extrem gering
währenddessen sie schreiben dass 100
menschen in deutschland pro jahr sterben
würden am verschlucken eines
kugelschreibers ist doch nicht ihr ernst
dieses ging hier unterbringen na ja das
sind leider kinder die dann auch die
kugelschreiber in einzelteilen
auseinandernehmen und dann tatsächlich
dadurch versterben und immer insgesamt
sind es 1500 menschen durch die durch
verschlucken von fremdkörpern dieses
jahr sterben in deutschland nicht oder
sie ersticken ja weil das im hals
stecken bleibt und dass dann denkt ein
mann strand und ich sehe auch auf diesem
kugelschreiber kein hinweis also das
verschlucken dieses schreibgerät kann
zur tödlichen ersticken führen müsste
eigentlich drauf stehen weil es viel
gefährlicher ist also sagen wir mal
durch einen terrorismus anschlag zu tun
ist also viel häufiger ist als
terrorismus anschläge also die menschen
schätzen gefahren
statistisch nicht in der richtigen
reihenfolge ein nicht also wenn zum
beispiel ein neuer virus kommen
vogelgrippe oder sars oder so dann für
das oft dazu dass die leute erst mal
eine riesenangst haben genau an diesem
virus zu sterben
auch wenn 23 menschen im land sterben
ist es verglichen mit denen die durch
blitzschlag sterben relativ wenig also
immerhin 140 150 leute im jahr sterben
durch blitzschlag in deutschland oder in
griechenland durch esels auch ein paar
hundert tote wo ja oder einen thailand
durch herabfallende kokosnüsse und
trotzdem liegt keiner behält am strand
in thailand das
sehen die leute in falsche relation zum
beispiel 43 prozent aller menschen
sterben durch
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen und schützen
wir uns davor nein wir arbeiten sogar
gezielt darauf hin in dem wir uns falsch
ernähren und zu wenig bewegung haben
aber andere gefahren wie terrorismus und
ihren wird völlig überschätzt
und glauben sie mir einfach falsch
informiert oder sind hier rational ja
angst ist irrational immer wenn etwas
neues kommt oder was unbeherrschbar
erscheinendes wie ein neuer virus oder
ein terrorismus das ist ja auch was was
wir nicht einschätzen können da gibt es
diese sogenannten schläfer die jahre
lang mehr oder weniger unauffällig leben
und dann plötzlich menschen umbringen
karikaturisten umbringen wollen
das erscheint uns so unbeherrschbaren
die können überall unter uns sein wir
kennen sie nicht und das macht uns die
große angst nicht und weil es eben neu
ist aber trotzdem wir setzen uns jeden
morgen ins auto obwohl die gefahr ist
mit dem auto zu verunglücken ist ja viel
größer jetzt hat sie wollen jedoch
dauernd das neue album down neue
klamotten wenn der apple ein neues
smartphone rausbringt stehen die leute
schlange dafür also stimmt nur bedingt
er hat vor dem 9 naja gut also es gibt
natürlich auch immer ein neugier trieb
nicht also es gibt immer verschiedene
triebe im menschen
einer davon ist der neugier trieb es
besonders bei kindern ausgeprägt
deswegen können kinder ihre angst
überwinden indem sie auf bäume klettern
das hat aber auch einen entwicklungs
geschichtlichen hintergrund zum beispiel
eine ratte die nicht ständig überall auf
klettere die kriegt nicht genug zu essen
also dass man muss um nahrung zu finden
also hatte muss man dauernd irgendwo auf
klettern und muss dann auch die höhen
phobie überwinden also auch ratten haben
höhen vor bin und was ich gehört habe
sogar vögel haben flug phobie haben die
kleinen sprechen hier nochmals über die
rezepte die die angst eigentlich
loswerden
es gibt da ein zusammenhang auch
zwischen angst und aberglauben und es
trotzdem so beschreibt zb wir
unglaublich angst hat vor dem erbrechen
obwohl er eigentlich seit ungefähr 30
jahren sich nie mehr übergeben musste
während er dieses kapitel schreibt holz
anfassen muss und beten muss weil einen
fluch fürchtet da habe ich mich kurz
ertappt gefühlt dabei dass wir ja mal
wirklich dinge tun oder an dinge glauben
die ein bisschen absurd sind und ich
habe etwas mitgebracht das zum beispiel
hier ist mein talisman seit mehreren
jahren
das hat meine jüngere tochter wie man
mit gegeben und gesagt das ist ein
glücksbringer sind so lustig beendet ich
angehalten mit zwei reza vielen ländern
bin ich ein bisschen krank warum frage
ich glaube das machen viele menschen
also auch absolut rational denkende
menschen machen du hast nicht wenn man
jetzt zum beispiel in deutschen
flugzeugen fehlt nicht nur ein platz 13
sondern auch der platz 17 13 ist für die
deutschen und 17 ist für brasilianer und
italiener
da war ich neulich in einem türkischen
flugzeug da waren beide drin also 13 und
17 nicht aber ich wollte mich nicht bei
13 hinsetzen ich kann mir sitzt aus habe
ich mich auch ob ich nicht bei 13 hin zu
setzen obwohl ich selber weiß ist völlig
überzogen ist und mit nichts mit der
realität zu tun hat weil es ja auch
nebenan land eine andere zahl ist also
menschen denken sodass ihr wirklich so
da kommt immer wieder dieses
belohnungssystem was ja auch auf einem
sehr primitiven level ist das versucht
uns sozusagen eine endorphinen
ausschüttung zu geben wenn sie das ding
morgens einstecken haben sie eine kleine
endorphine ausschüttung weil sie denken
das wird mich vor allen gefahren dieses
tages schützen also der glaube daran
stets genau
ja das ist so dass jeder mensch also
auch die nichtreligiösen menschen im all
so was wie aberglauben haben und dass
wir also ich denke auch am freitag den
13 abends denke ich dann ja mal mensch
gott sei dank ist mir nichts passiert
heute sogar es gibt auch das sprichwort
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
gibt es die jungs patientin die eben
welche controls länge entwickeln
ja das war so in dem bereich der
zwangserkrankungen also gerade
vorgestern habe ich dann wenn patienten
gesprochen
wenn sie morgens aus dem haus geht dann
muss sie erstmal die kaffeemaschine
kontrollieren und
das nicht kontrollieren und dann geht s
dir aus zum auto und denkt vielleicht
habe ich sie doch wieder angeschaltet
und dann gibt es noch mal zurück und
dann ja dann geht das fünf mal hin und
her also wir müssen aber sehr viel
kontrollieren sodass sie dann
schließlich eine stunde mit dem
kontrollieren verbringen bevor sie zur
arbeit kommen und kommen deswegen auch
zu spät zur arbeit verlieren manchmal
den job deswegen weil sie so lange im
notorisch zu spielen kommt ne um wie
bekämpft nun raus ist dass der gleiche
wirklich bei der angststörung in dem man
sich exponiert und einfach nicht mehr
kontrolliert genau dasselbe wort heißt
reaktions verhinderung man muss sich
also auf die finger hauen so wenn man
das kontrollieren will man muss also aus
dem haus gehen und das aushalten zu
lernen aushalten lernen dass man den
ganzen tag in diesem zweifel ist
vielleicht ist die kaffeemaschine doch
anders
ich erkläre dass patienten natürlich
immer dass alle elektrischen geräte dann
ein kleines elektronisches bauteil drin
haben was bei überhitzung sich von
selbst abschaltet also das
wahrscheinlich gar nichts passieren
würde selbst wenn sie an wäre aber sie
müssen das eben aushalten den ganzen tag
rum kommen sie nach hause und dann
selbst wenn es mal an ist passiert
meistens nichts schlimmes außer dass ein
bisschen strom verplempert worden
die allermeisten menschen haben ja
solche ticks aber wir sprechen nicht
darüber sicht uns unglaublich peinlich
ja viele zwangs patienten also die
wirklich die schlimmsten und absurdesten
ticks haben die möchten ihr geheimnis
für sich behalten weil sie auch denken
ja dass andere leute das peinlich
empfinden können das liegt daran dass
dieser dieses ich nenne das immer dieses
angst tun was wir am gehirn haben oder
das ministerium für absurde angst dass
das redet uns dinge ein und dann haben
wir einen vernunft gehören das sagt uns
schon das ist blödsinn was du denkst
nicht also dass wenn uns gehören sagt
auch erzählt nicht anderen leuten denn
die lachen darüber nicht und sie
streiten dann immer deswegen haben viele
ist es auch schwierig manchmal die
behandlung bei angstpatienten weil sie
nicht ehrlich sind sie sagen nicht
erzählen nicht denn das die ganze
wahrheit gibt irgendwie so ein total
absurden tipp den sie mal erlebt haben
einen patienten also man erlebt schon
die uhr keksen sachen ich hatte mal
einen zahnarzt er angst hatte vor ärzten
und er hatte dann so einen schweren
fernabsatz und es dann nicht hingegangen
es ist ja dann also
zum arzt gegangen der hat ihm gesagt er
muss jetzt ins krankenhaus das motorrad
muss operiert werden
da hat er sich so aufgeregt dass ein
herzinfarkt gekriegt hat und noch ein
schlaganfall ende her und hat dann acht
wochen in einem in einer intensivstation
mit dem leben gekämpft nicht und als wir
dann schließlich gerettet hatten dann
also ich war da auf intensivstationen
habe ich ihn mal gefragt was ist jetzt
nach acht wochen wo sie täglich zwei
ärzte an ihrem krankenbett stehen hatten
haben sie jetzt die angst vor ärzten
verloren sagt nein exposition habe
nichts gegen ein wenn bei diesem
stichwort noch einmal bleiben die
exposition ich frage mich immer was ist
eigentlich in meinem leben besser
evolution oder revolution also ist es
klüger an mir zu arbeiten
oder ist es klüger die umgebung zu
verändern zu versuchen man kann ja
eigentlich beide wege gehen
ja ich glaube man sollte sich also sich
selbst arbeiten weil das ist weniger
arbeit
das ist anstrengender aber ich habe
wahrscheinlich weil ich auch deutlich
älter als ich habe es aufgegeben die
gesellschaft zu verändern nicht also
mann
ich denke dass gesellschaften sich nicht
groß ändern da kann man machen was man
will dann kann man sich auf den kopf
stellen nicht ich bin froh dass wir
einen relativ freien gesellschaft leben
derzeit und man kann sich ja die
gesellschaft aussuchen wo man hingeht
nicht jeder kann sich das auch sehr weiß
ich es aussuchen kann kann sollte das
machen aber er sollte man an sich selbst
arbeiten das weil das einfach
überschaubar ist das problem
kommt drauf an also ich muss ja nicht
immer gleich von der ganzen gesellschaft
reden gehen wir zurück zum spinnen
beispiel man kann sich entscheiden das
bier einfach nicht mehr im keller
sondern im kühlschrank zu lagern wo
vergleichsweise wenig spielen zu hause
sind
keller und trotz trotz drohenden spinnen
einfach oder sie nehmen sie mal fand der
spinnen ja
lassen sie ihren mann eine spinne
anfangen einfangen und nehmen sie die in
der hand und machen sie das drei-
viermal und dann ist die spinne angst
weg ich sage immer was machen die ich
mache das mit der spinne sie setzen sich
auf die nummer 13 werde ich ja ein
entsprechendes flugzeug stehen vielen
dank für dieses gespräch
jeder klasse auch nächste woche geht es
hier wieder um angst angst vor dem krieg
angst vor dem elend und angst vor
perspektivenlosigkeit treiben millionen
menschen in die flucht
hierzulande haben die angst vor
überfremdung vor sozialen spannungen
oder vor dichte stress damit sind wir
mitten drin im thema der migration nicht
debattiere mit den nationalräten gehabt
pfister von der cvp und balthasar
glättli von den grünen was solidarität
mit flüchtlingen bedeutet und was
gerechtigkeit von uns verlangt jetzt
aber wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]